many ccsd teachers are facing problems
when it comes to health insurance like
being able to find a provider or simply
have their bills covered sally jaramillo
live in the newsroom tonight sally you
spoke to some of those teachers what are
they telling you
yes i did some teachers didn't want to
be identified but they tell me these
issues with their insurance have gotten
worse over the last couple of months
this all starting since the end of last
year today they simply want to receive
the benefits they deserve
i think there are a lot of issues that
not only myself but other teachers some
teachers are having trouble finding a
doctor others having trouble getting
elective surgeries covered by their
health insurance luanne wagner has been
a teacher for 24 years and says in her
entire career she's never seen anything
like this my situation
i'm i'm paying for the preferred
provider insurance for my dental
and then out of the blue i found out
through my dentist office that i've been
switched to an hmo wagner says she's in
shock over the change i was told as
there was a glitch in the system
people's insurances got switched but
then for us to get it switched back
we're being told that we have to file an
appeal this is extremely difficult for
her and her family her husband needing a
dental procedure now if we have to pay
out of pocket it's going to be over a
thousand dollars patrick cassell is an
insurance broker with multi-care group
he's been servicing the state of nevada
for over 30 years and says the school
district health problems have been going
on for decades depending on who the
carrier is and depending on how things
are being set up it can be very
difficult to get access to a doctor in
less than 90 days casell also added the
solution could be pretty simple and open
up their own medical clinics
strategically throughout the valley if
they did that then then all their people
would have access to seeing doctors
quicker and all wagner wants our
benefits
need to improve
casell adds there's no excuse to receive
a bill and not have access to someone
who can't explain what the problems are
i also reached out to the school
district about this they share some
background information on how ccsd is
working to have tht health be open and
honest that link can be found on our
website 8newsnow.com reporting from the
newsroom sally jaramillo live local now